le 16 août 2019 cet article du wall
street journal lance une information
insolite
donald trump souhaiterait racheter le
groënland
ce qui passe dans un premier temps pour
un gag est vite confirmée par
l'intéressé le groenland je ne sais pas
ça a été dévoilée d'une façon ou d'une
autre c'est quelque chose dont nous
avons parlé il appartient
essentiellement au danemark
nous sommes de très bons alliés avec le
danemark nous protégeons le danemark
comme nous protégeons une grande partie
du monde
le concept donc apparu et j'ai dit
stratégiquement c'est intéressant
d'acheter nous serions intéressés mais
nous allons voir leur parler un peu dès
le départ la réponse des doyennes
landais ainsi que celle du danemark
auquel ce territoire autonome est
rattachée est sans appel c'est non j'ai
déjà dit que le groenland n'est pas à
vendre et ce n'est pas un jeu de plus en
plus de personnes voient des
opportunités au groenland
mais ce que nous souhaitons ce sont des
partenaires pour le développement
commercial du groenland pour la première
ministre danoise la proposition du
président américain et je cite absurde
sanctions diplomatiques immédiate de la
maison blanche
la visite de trump au danemark prévue
les 2 et 3 septembre suivant est annulé
le danemark est un pays très spécial
avec des gens incroyables mais étant
donné les propos de la première ministre
mme été frédéric scène affirmant qu'elle
n'aurait aucun intérêt à discuter de
l'achat du greenland je reporterais
notre réunion prévue dans deux semaines
pour une autre fois par la suite
quelques appels téléphoniques apaise les
tensions entre les deux pays
preuve d'un rapprochement en avril
dernier le gouvernement groenlandais
accepte quelques 12 millions de dollars
d'aidé américaine pour des projets
civils
puis le 10 juin avec le feu vert de
copenhague les américains rouvrent même
leur consulat ouvre une lande 67 ans
après l'avoir fermé le groenland un
bijou de plus de 2 millions de
kilomètres carrés au coeur de l'arctique
avec la fonte de la calotte glaciaire
une zone économique exclusive de plus en
plus convoité tant sur le plan
économique que stratégique
la deuxième plus grande île
monde est une porte d'entrée des routes
maritimes de l'arctique c'est aussi le
terreau d'une possible l'exploitation
offshore dans le futur son sol dont on
pourrait aussi extraire les fameuses
terres rares ces métaux utilisés par
exemple dans la fabrication de
smartphones
jusqu'à présent la chine est le
principal fournisseur de ces matériaux
la perspective d'une nouvelle
exploitation au groenland pourrait être
un atout pour les etats-unis dans la
guerre commerciale qui l'oppose à l'
empire du milieu washington semble ne
pas pouvoir se passer du royaume
scandinave allié historique fidel
on se souvient par exemple que les
danois ont participé aux guerres d'irak
et d'afghanistan
aux côtés des américains